this video is brought to you by mischief
hey wisecrack somehow even longer haired
Jared here and today we're talking about
a movie that bitterly divides the
wisecrack team we've spent hours going
back and forth on ourself isolated Skype
calls on whether the film is deep or
dumb zack snyder's watchmen those of us
on the pro watchman's deep side contend
that zack snyder playfully twists Alan
Moore and Dave Gibbons seminal comic
injecting his own signature style to
satirize pop-culture and comic book
films nowadays however those of us that
think watchman's dumb claims Schneider
not only completely missed the point of
Moore's graphic novel but betrays
everything Watchmen originally stood for
so who's right well let's dig in in this
wisecrack edition on Zack Snyder's
watchman deep or dumb but before we get
into it I want to give a shout out to
this week's sponsor mischief if you
don't know what mischief is it's a
company that releases drops every two
weeks ranging from viral digital
experiences to high price items that
means in the past they've dropped Jesus
shoes a $1,425 pair of sneakers with
holy water in the soles that sold out
instantly and were subsequently featured
on Late Night with Seth Meyers a text
message bot that generates AI feet picks
and the office slack where they
recreated all 201 episodes of the office
inside of slack just as if Michael and
Dwight were working together in 2020
none of their drops have ever been the
same so you never know what you're gonna
get you may have seen some of these go
viral on reddit or even cable news so
here's how you can get access to their
future drops before anyone else they
recently released an app to allow fans
to get drops early drops can sell out
within seconds so the earlier you can
get access the better chance you'll have
to secure a drop fans will also be able
to access exclusive drops twice a month
and see what items have been dropped in
the past so download the mischief app
today by going to ms CHF dot-com that's
ms CHF dot-com or search ms CHF in the
App Store or on Google Play and now back
to the show a quick note before we begin
there are three different cuts of
watchmen available for the purposes of
this video we're going to go with Zack
Snyder and analyze his preferred version
so for me the director's cut is really
the
you know which has the de pollicis death
and all right let's get into a quick
recap the film opens in an alternate
timeline where the emergence of
anonymous heroes has dramatically
changed the world as we know it the u.s.
won the Vietnam War and Richard Nixon is
now serving his third term as president
in 1985 but Cold War tensions between
the Soviets in the u.s. have reached a
tipping point each side on the precipice
of firing nuclear warheads making things
worse
former vigilantes are beginning to
mysteriously die the comedian and early
masked hero is found dead flung from his
apartment window the murder prompts
another masked vigilante Rorschach to
investigate and warn other prominent
crime fighters of the impending danger
these include Nite Owl Silk Spectre
Ozymandias and the super man himself dr.
Manhattan
turns out all these murders were a
distraction for Ozymandias master plan
to kill millions of people and frame dr.
Manhattan why you might ask
well to unite the Soviet Union and
United States against a common enemy
thus averting nuclear holocaust now
before we can determine if Snyder either
betrays or skillfully adapts Watchmen
first we need to understand the comic
book that serves as its basis at its
core Alan Moore and Dave Gibbons
Watchmen is a deconstruction of
superhero comics comics prior to
Watchmen were made in the Bronze Age
which came directly after and largely
mimicked the Silver Age a time when they
were at their height of popularity yet
were stifled by government regulations
during the Silver Age the comics code
censored them so that they had to adhere
to strident rules advocating that good
should always triumph over evil and
forbidding any sexual perversion or
excessive violence the Bronze Age
largely replicated many tropes of the
Silver Age though it's comics were
darker and more laden with social
commentary however by the 1980s comics
were beginning to more meaningfully
rebel against these restrictions giving
way to Watchmen which obliterated these
rules altogether Watchmen depicts a
world where things aren't black and
white the so called heroes are morally
conflicted and sometimes downright awful
even the villains nefarious plot is all
in the name of averting nuclear
Armageddon just take it from Alan Moore
I think with things like Watchmen if
they succeed it's because they transcend
the superhero
genre they take it somewhere it had not
previously been the more hopeless the
genre the better really because people
are gonna be more surprised if you do
something good with it
zack snyder's watchmen emerged in a
similar period to its namesake comic
superhero films had been dominating the
pop culture landscape x-men spider-man
and later Iron Man assured in a
resurgence of family-friendly
superheroes at the multiplex these films
dominated the box office in turn leading
to darker more adult superhero stories
like The Dark Knight so the time was
seemingly perfect for Snyder to
obliterate the family-friendly
reputation of superhero films and adapt
Watchmen not as a satire of comic books
but of comic book movies Snyder does so
by filling his version of Watchmen with
graphic violence most superhero films
eschew the inherent violence their
so-called heroes cause Batman punches
thugs senselessly Ironman blasts bad
guys with his rays and yet we never saw
any of the carnage these violent acts
would naturally cause everything is a
hundred percent pg-13 but in Watchmen we
see everything take for instance the
scene where Dan and Laurie are attacked
by a gang in an alleyway in the comic
the scene is just Dan and Laurie
punching a few goons we see a few
bloodied faces a broken arm but that's
it in Snyder's version however this
seems depicted in exacting detail detail
that YouTube will probably flag us for
showing uncensored sorry one could argue
that all this war was intentional snyder
commenting on the dark nature the film
said what's popular about the Dark
Knight is that it's a superhero movie at
its core when Batman puts on his costume
that's badass yeah Batman go kick some
ass Watchmen is an entirely different
experience it punishes the audience it
says oh you like the comedian oh he's a
rapist by the way I wanted people to
think it's going to be a standard
superhero movie and then they're
confronted by all these ideas by
showcasing this violence Snyder draws
attention to how comic book films refuse
to acknowledge the destruction and
darkness implicit to the idea of
vigilantism satirizing superhero films
just as more did to comics before him so
pretty deep right well look there's no
denying that Zack Snyder is a gifted
filmmaker who can stage an action
sequence like no other
but these intricate fights are a
significant departure from the graphic
now
which in comparison is fairly light on
action yes of course there are fight
scenes scattered throughout the book but
they're always depicted in hyper
realistic fashion quick brutal and over
in less than a page or two or three more
here Lampoon's the typical long-winded
elegantly staged superhero fight by
depicting what these fights would
actually look like in reality by
contrast as youtuber Captain Christian
notes the most vivid depiction of
violence comes not from traditional
superhero antics but as a result of
Ozymandias destruction of New York more
never wanted to glorify watchman's
heroes or their antics when heroes look
back on their past it's a pathetic form
of nostalgia the comic even frequently
invokes a perfume called nostalgia to
drive the point home as such all the
present-day fight scenes in the comic
deliberately don't match the rose-tinted
way the supers view their past heroics
the best example of this is Hollis
Mason's death more juxtaposes Mason
getting beat to death with the old man
flashing back to his glory days beating
up the baddies and saving the day yet in
the present reality not a single punch
of the elderly Hollis is shown only his
fantasies of youthful violence
however in Snyder's version of Hollis
Mason's death the elder crimefighter
goes out with a bang landing a series of
punches and dying with a kind of macho
dignity the fight scene only reinforces
Mason's rose-tinted vision of his past
he really was just as heroic as he
thinks he was which is the antithesis of
what Moore was saying in the comic by
giving us a veritable show of badassery
Schneider doesn't so much as subvert the
genre he reinforces it whereas the comic
was anti nostalgia the film is adamantly
Pro nostalgia when Silk Spectre a night
I will dawn their capes again it's a
moment of triumph in Snyder's version
there are even hero shots of the two the
comic features Silk Spectre a night I
will reliving their glory days by having
a nerdy discussion about how to
accommodate fire victims by moving a
steering column the rest culminates in
them serving coffee to their wards
by contrast Snyder has night owl
epically shred a water tower with a
Gatling gun
while Silk Spectre does a bona fide
superhero landing superhero whereas the
comic depicts an impotent nerd needing
to play with his gadgets to feel like a
man the film cures this impotence with
actual badassery by glorifying these
superheroes actions both in the present
and past Snyder undercuts the moral
ambiguity of the original Watchmen
glossing over many of the less desirable
traits of the characters take Rorschach
a character the anarchist more created
to make fun of Steve Ditko signed ran
inspired the question more portrays
Rorschach as a misanthrope who was
obsessed with other people fun he reads
the new frontiersman a far-right paper
that supports the KKK
Echo's reagan-era talking points about
welfare queens called Silk Spectre a
bloated aging [ __ ] and just generally
stands for everything that more
personally too tests Snyder keeps a few
of these flourishes the first Silk
Spectre of bloated aging [ __ ] but keeps
mostly to be more appealing nihilistic
journal injuries even the questionable
comments Rorschach makes are repurposed
in Snyder's version for instance in the
comics and the movie Rorschach
speculates if Ozymandias could be a
homosexual this was meant to be more of
a critique on Rorschach's obsession with
so-called deviant sex but in Snyder's
version Rorschach's belief is taken as
fact
Ozymandias is revealed to have a hidden
file on his computer labeled boys thus
Rorschach's worldview is given more
extra legitimacy instead of the morally
complex weirdo from the comics Rorschach
becomes the voice of reason and the
audience surrogate of Snyder's film so
we're stuck in a bit of a stalemate
between deep or dumb which means only
one thing
Watchmen may have started out as just a
Lampoon on the superhero genre but as
Moore wrote the series it began to
become something far deeper Watchmen
started off as a silly ass superhero
story but what I eventually came to the
conclusion of about Watchmen was the
most important thing in it was it
structured and I think at the end that
Watchmen structure was what it was about
it was about a certain way of viewing
reality it was about a kind of
perception which I think was perhaps not
as prominent in 1985 as it is now
and as I think it will be in the near
future it's not a linear perception of
things that we do increasingly have in
the 21st century
see more wanted to challenge readers
perception he believed in a post
relativity / Einstein world time could
no longer be considered a Dulaney
construct how we perceive the world was
inherently incomplete events don't occur
linearly but are happening
simultaneously through the structure of
Watchmen and in particular through dr.
Manhattan and Ozymandias more sought to
prove this point just as dr. Manhattan
views time nonlinearly the comic is
structured so that the past present and
future are constantly blurring together
we tried to make watchmen structured so
that images recur all the way through
linking the present with the past and
the future
giving foreshadowings of things that
have yet to come giving echoes of things
that have already happened and later in
the comic Ozymandias watches events
unfurl on multiple television screens
mirroring how a person would read the
comic itself Adrian Veidt is watching
six channels at once and so at various
points and Watchmen are the readers its
multi-channel viewing by exposing
readers to a nonlinear comic book more
sought to challenge how readers perceive
their own reality
similarly Snyder uses his version of
Watchmen to comment on the same except
for Snyder he isn't interested in how
time and space shape perceptions of
reality instead the filmmaker zeroes in
on how pop culture and media have warped
people's perceptions with their comic
Alan Moore and Dave Gibbons were saying
superheroes are kind of funky aren't
they we build upon that with a movie
that acknowledges that superhero movies
have affected pop culture to prove this
point Snyder Phil's Watchmen with
touchstones from pop culture with one
crucial addition superheroes by doing so
Snyder literalizes the impact of comic
book films on viewers showing how the
emergence of superheroes changes
familiar moments in pop culture that we
all know and remember Watchmen almost
superimposes its heroes on your world
which then changes how you view your
world through its prism that's the
genius of this book that's what we try
and do in the movie the movie is a
challenge sort of like the book is a
challenge to your icons your morality
how you perceive pop culture how you
perceive mythology and for that matter
how you perceive God everything in
Watchmen is filtered through pop culture
even history itself
when dr. Manhattan fights in the Vietnam
War Snyder recreates this historical
moment through the prism of the most
famous Vietnam War movie ever made
Apocalypse Now using the same music you
from Coppola film later Schneider uses
his soundtrack choices to reference the
art film Koyaanisqatsi life out of
balance
[Music]
that non-narrative film juxtaposes
beautiful scenes of nature with the
chaos of modern life an apt choice for a
man who left earth because of the mayhem
of humanity even the war room Richard
Nixon and his generals use is modeled
after a famous film fight it here this
is the war room all these examples
expose how we perceive and filter the
world through media and pop culture it's
not just a meta wink that Hollis Mason
has a copy of Moore's Watchmen on his
shelf it's yet another example of how
pop culture a comic book like Watchmen
influenced and shaped Snyder's and by
proxy our perception of the world
this theme culminates with Ozymandias
watching dozens of TV screens a la the
comic book but unlike Moore's original
intent
Ozymandias watching these screens
mirroring how viewers read the comic
Schneider instead uses this moment to
play on how reality is warped by pop
culture all the images on the screen
reference different films and programs
that influenced and shaped Zack Snyder
the filmmaker there's road warrior
Looney Tunes The Day the Earth Stood
Still
fail-safe and more so what are we to
make of Snyder's watchmen as the
filmmaker betrayed everything Alan
Moore's comics stood for glorifying it's
heroes and compromising the moral
ambiguity of Moore's work or has Snyder
skillfully adapted Watchmen for our pop
culture saturated time ultimately it all
depends on your perception if you view
Watchmen through the lens of Moore's
original intent then watchman's pretty
dumb but if you view the film through
Snyder's signature style and vision then
the film could be considered deep even
after all this we're still pretty split
on the merits of this movie but for what
it's worth I tend to lean towards the
deep side whereas many of our writers
lean towards dumb but honestly I can see
both sides so what do you think is
Watchmen deep or dumb as your perception
of the film changed it all let us know
in the comments below thanks to all our
patrons for supporting the channel and
our podcasts don't forget to subscribe
and we'll catch you next time guys and
before you go don't forget to check out
mischiefs new app go to ms CHF comm
click the link in the description or
just search ms CHF in the App Store or
on Google Play and as always thanks for
watching guys peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]